mais là messieurs bonsoir c'est ce matin
très tôt qu est mort d'un cancer
l'ancien shah d'iran mohammed reza
pahlavi
ok il était âgé de 60 ans la nouvelle a
été annoncée sans détails par la
présidence de la république égyptienne
à 14h10 radio téhéran a diffusé
l'information ajoutant quelques minutes
après ce commentaire
le sanguinaire du siècle est enfin morts
il y à un mois précisément que l'ancien
shah d'iran avait été admis à l'hôpital
mais a dit du caire il était entré en
compagnie du président sadate
vous le voyez ce sont les toutes
dernières images de l'ancien souverain
que nous possédions mohammed reza
pahlevi sera enterré mardi dans la
capitale égyptienne
il sera enterré à la mosquée el rifaï au
pied de la citadelle du caire
ici là où son père avait été inhumé
pendant quelques années
le président sadate assistera à la
cérémonie funéraire
le chef de l'état égyptien qui se
trouvait à alexandrie au moment de
l'annoncé de la mort du chat a décidé de
reporter le discours qu'il devait
prononcer ce soir à l'occasion des fêtes
de la révolution égyptienne et s'est
adressé tout à l'heure à son pays à la
télévision il a annoncé que les obsèques
de mardi serait officielle bien que le
chat est demandé des funérailles très
simple mais at il ajouté nous aurons
tout le respect pour cet homme qui était
un frère un frère musulman
un homme qui a appuyé l'egypte dans les
moments difficiles et le président
sadate a ajouté que la famille de
l'ancien shah continuerait à résider en
egypte nous allons bien sûr analyser les
conséquences de la mort de l'ancien shah
d'iran nous serons en liaison avec
téhéran avec les états unis
nous aurons la réaction de monsieur
chapour bakhtiar mais la première
question qui vient à l'esprit et les
otages amérique ces cinquante otages que
vous voyez ici que vous allez voir et
qui sont retenus en iran depuis huit
mois maintenant les étudiants islamiques
exigeait le retour du shah en iran afin
qu'ils soient jugés en échange de leur
libération
maintenant que le chat est mort ces
otages bernard de médias mines ont ils
des chances d'être libéré très vite
malheureusement nourrit pour une simple
raison ce n'est plus ce n'était déjà
plus le chat qui intéressait khomeiny
c'est le procès public des états unis et
de leurs activités en iran sous le
régime du chah qui peut servir de
monnaie d'échangé
il ya tout juste un mois j'étais à
teyran j'ai rencontré six étudiants
islamiques qui ont pris en otage il y a
maintenant plus de huit mois
ces 52 américains je leur ai posé la
question je leur ai demandé est ce que
le marché que vous proposiez le 4
novembre la date de la prise d'otages à
savoir le chat contre les étages est ce
que ce marché est toujours valable
le jeune homme qui était assis en face
de moi sourit et s'est contenté de
répondre si le chat vit en iran ne
logeront mais ce n'est pas suffisant
nous exigeons maintenant l'aveu de la
bouche même du président américain du
président des états unis des crimes
l'aveu des crimes commis par les
américains en iran et la restitution de
tous les biens du chat cette réponse est
toujours valable aujourd'hui
les iraniens voulaient le chat vivant
pour mieux le tu es mort ils ne
représentent strictement plus rien pour
eux et cela confirme e
les premières déclarations des
dirigeants islamique à téhéran teyran où
la nouvelle de la mort de mohammed reza
pahlavi n'a pas donné lieu à de grandes
manifestations
l'analyse de l'un des correspondants de
l'agencé france presse en iran générale
annonce de nouvelles ne voulons pas sans
cadavre nous exigeons la restitution des
biens trouver une solution il a rarement
dans le monde
un homme d'état n'aura été autant admiré
puis à vie par son peuple
sollicité puis rejetées par l'occident
après 37 ans de règne le dernier
autocrates de droit divin a été détrôné
par plus fanatiques que lui son exil
embarrassé tous ceux qui ont tenté de
l'accueillir sur leur sol sauf le
président égyptien sadate dont on peut
saluer le courage de plus l'ancien shah
était au moment où il a quitté l'iran
millet par la maladie qui finalement a
aujourd'hui eu le dernier mot
laissons l'histoire juger tranquillement
de l'action de mohammed reza pahlavi et
revoyons ce que fut pendant 37 ans le
règne du shah reza shah encore vivants
de 1925 à 1941 et son fils mohamed la
mort en exil sera leur destin comme mais
le 26 octobre 1919 mohamed à 6 ans
lorsque son père devenu premier ministre
s'empare du trône et son de la dynastie
pahlavi
le prince héritier reçoit une éducation
à l'occidentale en suisse avant de
parfaire son instruction militaire en
iran sous la houlette d'officiers
français en 1941 la seconde guerre
mondiale ébranle le moyen-orient on met
un coup d'état pro nazi et shoot peu en
irak
reza shah qui veut rester neutre
refusent le passage sur son territoire
aux britanniques et aux soviétiques qui
s'appuie sur d'anciens traité alors
londres et moscou qui depuis deux
siècles se disputer des pouilles à un
empire perse chancelant déclenché une
double invasion
à 22 ans mohamed succède à son père qui
connaîtra l'exil et mourra en 1944
mohamed obtient de churchill de
roosevelt et staline venus à téhéran en
43 une promesse d'évacuation dès la fin
des hostilités en 46 pourtant les
soviétiques sont toujours là contre la
promesse de ratification d'un traité
pétroliers par un parlement qui ne peut
être élu que dans un iran totalement
libres nous à mettre persuade staline de
retirer ses troupes mais en 47
le nouveau parlement élu d'une façon
discutable repousse ce traité staline a
trouvé plus rusés cuit le jeune
souverain n'a plus qu'à ajouter cet
ennemi de poids à la liste déjà longue
des adversaires que lui a laissé son
père notamment un religieux comme eni et
un docteur en droit
mossadegh en 1949 sur six balles tirées
à bout portant une atteint la mâchoire
l'autre l'épaule et 3 traverse la
casquette mise en cause le parti
communiste ou des est décrété hors la
loi mais l'agitation s'étend et en mars
51 lun plat cadrage mara
placé par le ch à la tête du
gouvernement est assassiné pour le
remplacer le souverain fait appel au
docteur mossadegh démocrate et leader du
front national mossadegh nationalise la
compagnie pétrolière anglo iranienne un
véritable état dans l'état
tout en entretenant l'agitation contre
la monarchie qu'il veut abattre en 53
c'est la rupture le chat sein de céder
et part pour bagdad et rome
sept jours plus tard c'est le retour
triomphal facilitée par la cia qui a mis
à profit l'attachement du petit peuple à
la monarchie les outrances de mossadegh
et les craintes de la bourgeoisie modéré
21 officiers paye aussitôt de leur ville
rêveur en matière de stratégie politique
des centaines d'autres sont arrêtés
quant à mossadegh jugé condamné est
gracié il nouera presque centenaire en
l'après mossadegh est marquée par la
relance de la réforme agraire commencé
en 51
mais les inégalités restent criantes en
1963 c'est la révolution sociale la
rénovation urbaine d'un participation et
le vote des fans ce n'est pas assez pour
la gauche c'est beaucoup trop pour les
conservateurs et le clergé chiite
alors à part l imam commenee ennemi juré
de la monarchie
si qui ne reconnaît que la loi coranique
il ira en prison à plusieurs reprises
avant de connaître l'exil en 1965 65,7
aussi l'année du second attentat montée
manquée contre l'avis du chat qui
dénonçait alliance contre nature du
rouge et du noir
deux ans plus tard persuadé de sa
réussite politique et économique combler
sur le plan familial à la suite de son
mariage avec farah diba une jeune femme
qui lui a donné une postérité mal le
chat estime que le moment est venu de se
faire couronner solennellement le 27
octobre 67 au lendemain de son 48e
anniversaire dans le vieux palais de
gaulle est stable des centaines de
courtisans et de diplomates attendent
que le sachent à quoi fui même de la
couronne impériale il tourne ensuite la
shahbanou régente tandis que le jeune
reza est élevé au rang de prince
héritier mais déjà mohamed sont à une
autre cérémonie
en 1971 le 2500e anniversaire de l'
empire perse puis fourni l'occasion
d'accrocher la dynastie pahlavi à
l'histoire de l'an pire on dresse un
immense camp face aux tombeaux des rois
pour les invités et l'on procède à une
reconstitution d'ailleurs faire discuter
de toute l'histoire guerrière du pays si
georges pompidou à leur président de la
république française juge préférable de
se faire représenter
d'autres chefs d'état têtes couronnées
ou chefs de gouvernements feront le
déplacement
apportant ainsi leur caution morale un
régime dans la presse mondiale
commencent à dénoncer les excès même
quito est présent ses extravagances
coûte la bagatelle de 500 millions de
francs lourd mais peu importe le chat
qui a échappé de peu à deux attentats
est convaincu qu'il est venu sur terre
pour accomplir une mission je lui ai
avoué
que
toute ma vie ça n'a été qu'une
succession surtout pendant une période
de ma vie de rêve d'apparition mystique
je crois que j'ai vraiment une mission à
accomplir les succès qui ont été
enregistrées jusqu'à présent certains
sont inexplicables moi je l'expliquais
justement par cette autre force et je
suis sûr que tant que j'aurai à
accomplir la mission et bien je serai là
la mission sera accomplie lorsque de ton
sera fini et bien fini
c'est ainsi que vous expliquez vous
miraculeux disons succès par rapport aux
tentatives d'assassinât qui guérit
contre je n'ai pas d'autre explication
mm non seulement cela ce qui s'est passé
dans ce pays
si vous comparez mon pays maintenant à
ce qu'il était il ya dix ans une
trentaine d'années les premières années
70 se place sous le signe de l' euphorie
le chat ouvre grand les robinets du
pétrole et le grand chef en 75 dispose
de 100 milliards de francs et il espère
conduire son pays au rendez-vous
technologique du 21e siècle c'est la
grande industrialisation fondée sur
l'énergie nucléaire qui remplacera dans
30 ans le pétrole en voie d'épuisement
constructeurs et banquiers le chat voit
se présenter autour de lui tous ceux qui
ont quelque chose à vendre ou qui
doivent emprunter
ces forces armées conseillé par quarante
mille américains sont les plus
puissantes de la région à washington on
ne compte que sur elle
en tant que seul maillon solide de
l'alliance du moyen-orient et on
encourage l'iran a joué le rôle de
gendarme dans le golfe persique le chat
vole donc au secours du sultanat doman
contre une rébellion téléguidé de moscou
via aden
mais finalement cette armée qui coûtent
des milliards ces généraux combler sont
ils prêts à se sacrifier pour le régime
l'histoire prouvera que non le revers de
la médaille le monde le connaît quand la
presse internationale publie des photos
du chat non celle d'un sportif qui en
suisse ou d'un bon père de famille dans
son palais mais celle d'un homme que
l'on accuse de se maintenir au pouvoir
que grâce à des tortionnaires
car on torture en iran depuis
cinquante-six date de la création de la
savak la police politique infiltrée
partout tout opposant communiste ou
bourgeois intellectuelle ouvriers peu
sur simple délation connaître les
cachots nous on ne sort que fusillé ou
pendu ou mutilés combien de victimes
le chat avouera un jour 2000 prisonniers
politiques ses adversaires politiques
10 100 1000 morts
en 1977 et l'explosion à la suite de la
création d'un parti unique à téhéran
mais c'est ici à washington à l'occasion
de la visite de mohamed pas la vie à
jimmy carter que le monde prend
conscience de la largeur du fossé qui
sépare désormais le souverain de son
peuple
les étudiants iraniens livres pendant
plusieurs heures une bataille acharnée
aux policiers américains qui tentent de
les disperser en iran début 78 on relève
60 n'aura comme et une centaine à tabriz
le 8 septembre un vendredi
il y à 700 morts à terre alors le chat
malade et désabusé parle d'une possible
démocratie à l'occidentale
naturellement il faut aller vers une
démocratisation et nous allons adopter
les mêmes lois qui existent déjà en
france pour les libertés d'expression
liberté de manifestation
nous allons vous copier
c'est ma volonté
après avoir mûrement réfléchi que c'est
la voie à suivre avec les pluralisme
politique
mais à téhéran on s'installe dans la
grève et les meutes on défie la loi
martiale tandis que l'armée ne bouge pas
en fait les iraniens ont les yeux
tournés vers une petite bourgade de la
région parisienne où la gâteau la
commune i qui tient enfin sa vengeance
d'ordre un ordre le chat doit partir
notre point de vue est extrêmement clair
que le gouvernement iranien soit dirigé
par un militaire dont par un civil ne
change rien au soulèvement populaire en
cours en iran ou bien ce soulèvement a
pour but de regagner la légitimité des
masses religieuse iranienne et jusqu'au
départ du shah avec son sens premier
ministre militaire ce soulèvement se
poursuivre
dans une capitale où l'anarchie s'est
installé le pouvoir est maintenant dans
la rue le chat constitue d'abord un
gouvernement militaire il fait arrêter
quelques-uns de ses proches
collaborateurs dont obeida qui sera
fusillé après la chute du régime puis le
gouvernement militaire est remplacé par
un gouvernement civil sous la direction
d'un modéré chapour bakhtiar mais il est
trop tard beaucoup trop tard le
souverain qui perd ans le 13 janvier 72
première des grandes étapes de l'exil du
chat le caire sera aussi la dernière
voilà donc pour cette vie du chat par
edouard laure andré guinée et joe louis
le sait le président giscard d'estaing
adressé un message de condoléances à la
veuve de l'ancien shah d'iran un message
a également été envoyée par la reine
d'angleterre et le président carter mais
aux états unis
pas de déclaration à la maison blanche
en revanche on a remarqué une réaction
de ronald reagan
le candidat républicain aux
présidentielles de gagnières la maison
blanche aurait été le premier à réagir
et avant le président américain revenant
sans doute aussi à la politique
étrangère des états unis
une nouvelle unité perdue depuis l'
affaire des otages avait joué un rôle
primordial en matière de sécurité dans
cette région
quand les intérêts des états unis la
mort est important l'agencé chine
nouvelle n'a fait aucun commentaire en
annonçant la nouvelle de même que
l'agent soviétique tasse en france une
réaction de l'udf qui parle du chat
comme de l'exemple même d'une vie
tragique son échec laisse tout le
moyen-orient dans une situation
difficile dit l'udf et puis il était
intéressant de savoir ce que pense
monsieur chapour bakhtiar de la
disparition de l'ancien souverain dont
il fut le dernier premier ministre vous
vous souvenez que chapour bakhtiar a été
victime d'un attentat lundi dernier à
son domicile parisien
ce qui montre bien que c'est lui qui
devient maintenant la cible numéro un
des extrémistes iranien serge me serais
à rencontrer monsieur bakhtiar tout à
l'heure il lui a d'abord demandé s'il
pensait que les otages américains
pouvaient être libéré rapidement tout
est possible avec
clic de khomeiny est lui-même en tête
donc tout ce qui caractérise et c'est
absolument l'imprévisible avis ces gens
là normalement évidemment et devrait
être libéré puisqu'il n'ya pas de des
changes du chat entre ces jeux entre les
comtés prisonniers de américain mais
cela ne peut pas être discutée je crois
que c'est le parlement qui trouveraient
prouvera finira par trouver une modalité
pour la mise en liberté ces otages
est ce que la mort du chat change
quelque chose pour vous pour moi rien
pour moi la question c'est la liberté
l'indépendance et le progrès de l'iran
que ça soit le régime monarchie sous sa
seule origine démocratique république
évidemment pas islamique
cela ne change pas grand chose c'est le
contenu et qui importe et non pas la
forme apparente jeu bakhtiar le chat
mort
je ne pense pas vous apprendre que c'est
vous qui est maintenant en première
ligne tout à l'heure la radio iranienne
a dit demander exiger votre extradition
pour que vous soyez jugé alors non je
vous en pensez je ne pense rien d'une
bande de fous qui dit toujours de métis
tous les jours ça n'a aucune importance
je suis un homme qui est lutte est
beaucoup plus car khomeiny pour la
liberté l'indépendance ferme une bande
l'idiot et surtout font reconnaître des
gens dont la logique vous avez vu la
figure de sova disant leurs ministres
des affaires étrangères qui en 5 minutes
s'est contredit six fois par conséquent
ce que racontent ces gens-là m'importe
vraiment cela m'étonne quand vous
entendez quelque chose de la radio
télévision iranienne que vous considérez
comme sérieux c'est pas sérieux ces gens
là par conséquent que je suis maintenant
l'homme à battre
ça c'est conforme à ce que je prévoyais
puisque monsieur khomeiny buffers
disparaît l'iran de la carte mondiale
il va en faire une
identité islamique et moi toujours j'ai
soutenu que l'islam se trouve ailleurs
aussi c'est l'iran qui m'intéresse et
l'iran sun à propos justement de
monsieur bakhtiar j'apprends à l'instant
même que le ministre iranien des
affaires étrangères monsieur gods ad
accuse la police française monsieur gods
ad accuse la police française d'avoir
été informé du projet d'attentât contre
l'ex premier ministre iranien monsieur
chapour bakhtiar survenu lundi dernier à
neuilly dans la banlieue parisienne
c'est ce qu'a déclaré tout à l'heure
monsieur le gotha des la dépêche vient
de tomber à l'est voilà donc pour l'iran
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire notamment ce
soir sur la mort de l'ancien shah d'iran
elle intervient il ne faut pas l'oublier
un moment crucial pour le gouvernement
iranien
secoué par une crise dont on ne va pas
très bien où en es l'issue ce qui fera
bien sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui comme hier
paul nahon
on parle en iran d'atteinte très graves
aux droits de l'homme on aurait aimé
dire ce soir qu'avec la mort du chat
c'est une page dramatique de l'histoire
de l'iran qui vient de se tourner on
aurait aimé pouvoir le dire mais
malheureusement ceux qui lui ont succédé
applique curieusement les mêmes méthodes
peut être pire
la terreur érigée en système de
gouvernement si aux tous premiers jours
de la révolution on pouvait à la rigueur
comprendre les violences et le sentiment
de vengeance d'une partie de la
population
aujourd'hui plus rien ne peut expliquer
ces tribunaux d'exception et les
exécutions massives depuis le retour de
l'ayatollah khomeiny en iran à téhéran
1800 personnes ont été passés par les
armes c'est le chiffre officiel donné
par le gouvernement iranien lui-même les
organisations internationales estime
elle que ce chiffre est plutôt de 6000
comme sous le chah on fusille les
opposants politiques en les faisant
passer pour de simples trafiquants de
drogue comme hier ceux qui sont aux
postes clés de l'état
mais cette fois des religieux purs et
durs trafic et font passer de véritable
petite fortune à l'étranger
il y a dix huit mois un immense espoir
était né en iran après le départ du shah
aujourd'hui la décomposition totale du
régime
la lutte pour le pouvoir la haine de ses
dirigeants sous couvert de l'islam et de
la lutte anti impérialiste
tout cela fait dire que les hommes ont
changé mais que les pratiques sont
restés rigoureusement les mêmes
tout à fait autre chose
un très grave attentat a eu lieu cet
après midi en belgique à anvers contre
des enfants juifs
l'un d'entre eux de nationalité
française a été tuée
un homme a tiré à la mitraillette sur un
groupe d'enfants de familles orthodoxes
juives
il attendait l'autobus de leurs vacances
ici a ouvert devant l'association
israélienne
aboud al israel les enfants entre 10 et
15 ans leurs valises et leurs pieds à 15
heures un homme tire avec un pistolet
automatique un enfant d'origine
française s'effondre mortellement
atteint une vingtaine d'autres sont
blessés dont sept graves mans l'auteur
de cet attentat est immédiatement arrêté
il porte un passeport marocain mais la
police pense que ce document est un faux
le meurtrier aurait déclaré que son
geste devait être jugé dans le cadre du
conflit israélo arabe
tous ces enfants appartiennent en effet
à des familles de diamantaires et la
plupart des ouvriers ou des négociants
du diamant à anvers sont de religion
juive orthodoxe
en bref maintenant arrivés tout à
l'heure à paris du roi hussein de
jordanie pour une visite privée de trois
jours au cours de laquelle il aura
néanmoins des entretiens avec le
président de la république
le souverain hachémite informera
notamment monsieur giscard d'estaing de
ses récents entretiens avec le président
carter portons sur le proche-orient donc
l'afghanistan je voudrais vous signaler
que demain après le journal de 20 heures
nous vous présenterons une édition
spéciale sur l'afghanistan après le
retour de nos envoyés spéciaux
philippe rochot et jacques dès qu'ils
ont passé un mois
parmi les rebelles afghans ils pourront
donc nous éclairer sur des aspects tout
à fait inconnue de ce conflit qui
malheureusement s'est terni ce en france
j'apprends qu'un très grave accident de
la circulation s'est produit ce matin
dans les alpes de haute provence la
collision de deux voitures a fait cinq
morts et deux blessés graves
cela s'est passé entre sainte tulle et
manosque sur la nationale 96 les deux
voitures se sont heurtées sur une ligne
droite
elle venait en sens inverse et on ignore
les raisons de cet accident
je vous propose maintenant de quitter
notre planète et de voguer vers d'autres
cieux
pour cela il vous faut être un peu
philosophe un peu alchimiste il vous
faut traîner le mystère avec jean louis
goût serre qui a signé les images qui
vont suivre et louis doucet allant dans
un monde où c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire il n'y a pas foule
la richesse de cet ensemble de mosaïques
récemment découvertes et sa rigueur
symbolique pause d'étranges jeanine aux
dires des spécialistes il faudra sans
doute des années pour trouver la clé de
ce langage cosmogonique recélant
peut-être la formule de la fameuse
pierre philosophale
tout cela c'est la mystérieuse
expérience du petit fils tu maharadjah
de lahore
il s'appelait hassan dina et ceux qui
l'ont connu s'accorde à dire qu'il était
un pur philosophe hermétique initiés aux
sources de l'himalaya par les moines
tibétains
cette chapelle 1 représente un tarot et
ça c'est très curieux parce que le tarot
dans l'histoire du tarot on a toujours
trouvé le tarot sous forme de jeux de
cartes
c'est à dire sur
du papier sur le carton mais ne jamais
sur les murs d'un chapelle un tank
en fait le tas roi des origines très
très lointaine très ancienne et à toutes
les civilisations du monde
oui en fait on peut renverser le mot et
voir dans ta rohart de tôtes
c'est-à-dire à l'égypte ancienne à
d'alchimie art d'hermès et c'est en fait
cette signification que dina retenue et
a voulu exprimer manifesté dans cette
chapelle puisqu'il aurait voulu livrer
un message bien le message du groupe de
jona peu secret mystérieux le message
c'est le message
alchimie c'est à dire la la recherche
d'une pierre philosophale qui
apporterait 10 ont la connaissance
universelle qui apporterait également la
meilleure médecine universel et pour les
initier à ces sciences étrange pour le
coma cette chapelle a vraiment un sens
profond
le sens important ccc la recherche de la
des mystères de la nature de la création
de tout l'univers ccc la quête de tous
les savants de tous les philosophes vous
êtes comment sont les gens vont imaginer
qui se passait des choses ici je crois
qu'il faut pas non plus imaginer des
choses qui se rapprocherait de la magie
noire
trois classes de l'imagination très très
vagabonde
en réalité dean a été un homme de
science un homme
de l'être aussi puisqu'il a écrit
plusieurs livres et c'était quelqu'un de
tout à fait sérieux qu'est-ce que vous
le ferez sacrément ici que nous le
pouvons pas lancer elle sait absolument
pas il s'agit pas du tout ça il s'agit
de protéger une oeuvre d'art parce que
il n'ya pas que le message philosophique
il y a également l'oeuvre d'art et ses
mosaïques sont sont absolument
remarquable un dernier mot nous ne
sommes pas une opinion mais en france
exactement au château des aveux guerre à
cruseilles près d'annecy
quelques télégrammes de sport le tour de
france à la voile la 4e étape le havre
honfleur a été remporté par le bateau
brest qui consolide ainsi sa position de
premier au classement général
je vous rappelle que demain antenne de
midi que vous présentera daniel bilalian
sera un an fleurs pour parler justement
de ce tour de france auquel participent
antenne 2 avec son propre bateau invités
- monsieur robert poujade
en tennis la france a remporté à vichy
la coupe de galéa devant l'espagne jeux
olympiques les médailles d'or plug
j'apprends à l'instant que la france a
enlevé le titre de championne olympique
par équipes au fleuret féminin donc
médaille d'or pour les femmes du fleuret
médaille d'or également pour le français
angelo parisi ça c'est un judo en judo
alors que jean luc rougé a été éliminé
en demi finale on comptait pourtant sur
lui pour une médaille
et puis le tiercé de cet après midi à
maisons laffitte alors attention vous
allez voir il est arrivé une petite
aventure cocasse au jeu créé fernandez
qui a été désarçonné avant le départ de
la course par son cheval oldman
celui-ci vous le voyez ayant pris le
goût de la liberté n'a pas voulu
rejoindre ses autres amis chevaux il a
donc gambader tout seul comme ça sur la
piste retardant de plusieurs minutes et
plusieurs dizaines de minutes même le
départ du tiercé mais vraiment il ne
voulait pas y aller
joie des spectateurs par parenthèse
c'est pas souvent qu'il y à une telle
aventure et puis finalement les chevaux
sont partis et à l'arrivée c'est en
garde douce montée par jean paul le
faire qui a passé le premier la ligne en
gare youth le numéro
s il est suivi vous allez le voir de
chèques donne le numéro un est en
troisième position
ce sera le numéro 2 dan again la
combinaison gagnante est donc le 13
las et le 2 et pour cinq francs vous le
voyez c'est à dire c'est qu'ils
rapportent 22000 27 francs dans l'ordre
et dans un ordre différent 2325 c'est ce
qu'on appelle un beau tiercé reste à
feuilleter la page météo aujourd'hui les
températures avoisinaient 20° sauf dans
le midi où elles sont montées jusqu'à
30° à peu près 25 30 demain sur les
côtes de l'atlantique le temps sera
nuageux avec des ondées orageuses et les
températures seront là en baisse partout
ailleurs il fera beau et chaud fin de ce
journal les dernières nouvelles à 23h35
avec hervé claude avec tous ceux qui ont
préparé ce journal je vous souhaite de
passer une très bonne soirée